is brad wright being frozen out of the
new stargate series or is he just
playing a very clever game
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so brad wright's had a new interview and
he's been talking about stargate again
mainly because of this new stargate he's
actually delivered
this fantastic project he's been
involved in to deliver an entirely new
stargate storyline generated completely
by artificial intelligence
basically he's got together with google
and they fed this computer 300 plus
scripts of stargate they then set some
character parameters
and basically
the computer created a brand new story
he's got some old favorites amanda
tapping michael shanks jewel state and
david hewlett david hewlett is by the
way one of my favorite like sort of main
characters um rodney is just great and
if when they do bring stargate back i
really hope there's a place for rodney
in there because he's just one of those
actors he's just great and everything
even when he's acting like a complete
bell and he's brilliant
anyway
so they got these guys to read through
the script on companion where
brad wright has a regular little podcast
i haven't seen it yet i can't wait to
see it if you have seen it please let me
know is it any good because um i'm
really i'm really hopeful it's actually
new stargate which is what we want isn't
it right
but in this interview he talked about
his plans for stargate he's talked about
how he was writing the initial storyline
he he has written a pilot double episode
and basically um he's given us a few
little tidbits he's basically said
general samantha carter will be leading
the show i actually also suggest though
that she's going to be directing
episodes and be really involved with
behind the camera but getting her
involved there and you know using the uh
using that as a bit of a tease to get
her back into the show
we will be fantastic
he's also talked about how the world
will probably end up knowing all about
stargate and the secret will be out
that's a big change to the original
story you know one of the things we
loved about stargate was that it had
this whole storyline going on but it was
contemporary it was it was actually in
our ex in our universe sort of thing um
it could be real so that would be a big
change for the show if that is actually
carried through into the amazon version
of what's being planned for stargate
he did again reiterate that the original
plans and his original story was kind of
put on hold initially by covid but then
he does make the point that migrating
from mgm to amazon
has now also put the series on hold
until the sale is finalized which may
not be until 2022 or mid 2022
this isn't going to happen
everything is on hold right now but he
does say a little bit more about the
original story that he's hoping to
develop and he did say that he wants a
new story he wants new characters but he
wants it to honor the original and he
wants to bring some characters back
potentially even richard dean anderson
definitely michael shanks definitely
amanda tapping
he wants to bring us back and he wants
to have sort of a blended new show with
new stories new you know um mythologies
to be explored you know we're doing
egypt is there something else we can
explore
and he wants to open up the entire
universe again
this is really what we want to hear and
i'm really hoping adam anderson are
listening to brad wright because we
don't want
a reboot that destroys the original and
pees all over it like
i'm going to say star trek now
start the new
naughty star trek really does trample on
a lot of what we consider star trek to
be what it should be and you know
changing the klingons changing the style
changing they changed everything you
know they've pedaled over cannon in lots
of ways we don't want stargate to do
that and for the love of god please
don't
but brad wright did go on to say
something else which made me a little
bit concerned and lots of videos i've
seen about this interview don't seem to
have really picked up on this but then
he goes on to say
he that he cannot envisage mgm or amazon
not doing something with stargate
now i'm going to read between the lines
here a little bit
that to me sounds like he doesn't know
what the current plans are now i've told
you in other videos i've actually got a
source that's reasonably close to mgm
and they've been able to tell me that
amazon are very very keen for stargate
to get up and running as quickly as
possible that's not going to happen
until the sale goes through like i say
but they're very very keen for this to
happen they consider it the sleeping
giant of sci-fi and they want it on our
screens as quickly as possible
pre-production work as much that this
can be done is being done
if brad wright isn't aware of that that
is concerning that suggests to me that
maybe amazon have took this over
the amazon want this done as quickly as
possible and they perhaps want their own
people to be leading it they consider
the franchise to be a really important
part of what they want to do in the
future they also then told mgm that they
wanted them to think a lot bigger and
the plans that they had in place was not
what they envisaged
so
are they maybe moving away from brad
wright's plans and and maybe getting
someone else to lead the project
if they are i would say that's a massive
mistake by amazon
if you want to get this franchise to get
a lot of excitement and to really get
the fans on side
get brad wright on side
if he is involved we will be a lot more
excited than if he isn't
but is it that he isn't involved or he
doesn't know what's going on anymore or
is it that he is playing a game
is he actually just being really careful
about what he's saying so he is teasing
that this is happening
but it's not green lit yet so he's got
enough sense not to say more than that
or is there another possibility
is it that he is
that this juggernaut that is amazon has
come into mgm maybe he is getting
sidelined a little bit so by talking
about amazon maybe he's playing a little
bit of a game
maybe he's just just getting the fans
hooked
now he hasn't said anything too deep so
he's not going to get into trouble with
amazon necessarily but he is just
making sure the fans are teased just
enough
that makes it really difficult for
amazon not to involve him or also not to
include his storyline ideas
maybe he is just putting the ball back
into amazon's court and saying you know
there you go this is what i've got in
mind and the fans are behind me so if
you don't support what i want to do then
you know i could make this really
difficult for you i could actually you
know turn the fans against you
and let's be honest the fans are already
in two minds about this i get a lot of
comments from massive fans of target and
they're incredibly excited a lot of
people don't really believe this is ever
going to happen and i don't blame you
either but a lot of people are
incredibly excited but one of the things
they say over and over again is is this
going to go on amazon if i'm going to
pay for an amazon subscription or god
forbid in the uk
stargate
at the moment at least is on the mgm
channel
stargate sg1 though
isn't stargat sg1 is only on amazon but
it's not part of prime you have to pay
for it either you have to buy the series
or you have to buy the episodes
stargate atlantis is on the mgm channel
and so is stargate sgu
but none of those are either part of
prime i have to pay for a second mgm
channel subscription so i'm paying my
prime subscription and my mgm
subscription
would it be conceivable
that amazon would put any new stargate
immediately onto the mgm
channel
it would make sense it would push that
channel and and recoup some of that
investment that amazon are putting in
but it would mean that i have to then
pay for another damn subscription
that is not going to go down well
now if they do that in america as well
it's just thing it's it's a subscription
with us within the subscription it's
just maddening and that isn't going to
be popular
also amazon generally as a company isn't
massively popular they were expecting
this sale of mgm to go through already
but it's getting bogged down because the
regulators aren't amazon's biggest fans
they think they are a little bit fuzzy
when it comes to the law they think this
is not really fair competition and you
know
there is a distinct possibility that
this sale actually
might not go through there's a big drive
actually for it not to go through
there's a lot of public opinion for it
you know pushing the regulators to not
let it go through
so amazon are on a bit of a knife edge
they're not the most popular company in
the world what they plan to do with the
stargate series might not be the most
popular thing in the world
and they might not be including brad
wright
if that is the case
the fans are going to be very nervous
even when this does get green lit
so let's hope that i am just reading
more into what he said than there is
let's hope i'm reading between the lines
and getting it on my way out
but from what he actually said i am a
little bit concerned so i would suggest
as stargate fans we get behind brad
right
we make videos like this
we make comments we get out there and
tell mgm exactly what we want them to do
with stargate and that we make sure brad
wright
is at least
involved hopefully though in charge and
at the helm
so
fingers crossed amazon listen
if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe hit that bell
notification and do all that it really
helps us out
join us on facebook the links in the
description and join us on discord and
tell me what you want to see from
stargate in the future the link is also
in the description as always guys please
stay safe and i will see you next time
[Music]